une séance de course presque ordinaire
marie-louise achète ce jour là un peu de
frais mais pas pour elle elle est agent
social de la ville de plaisir elle suit
donc scrupuleusement la liste de courses
on est attentif à ça il faut bien qu'on
leur apporte vraiment ce dont ils ont
besoin
bon ils peuvent pas sortir avec le
confinement c'est que verger qui lui a
remis sa liste ce plaisir wa bénéficie
depuis deux ans des êtres du service
maintien à domicile un service à nouveau
modifié dix personnes fragiles en ont
fait la demande
avec ce virus qui se propage partout ça
m'empêche d'accompagner la personne de
la mairie mais je me faisais à la fois
une sortie et les courses ou voyait
alors c'était agréable beaucoup 68 repas
sont distribués chaque jour
accompagnement pour des rendez vous
médicaux ou administratifs et appels
téléphoniques
une dizaine de personnes est mobilisée
dans ce service
qu'ils sachent que nous sommes présents
et nous répondons systématiquement de
façon personnalisée
à leur retour à nos sms
les personnes qui sont vraiment très
isolés nous allons aller faire sortir de
chez eux pour une petite demi heure là
une petite balade aux alentours de leur
domicile pour
d'effacer un petit peu ce cet isolement
ce service renforcé proposé par la
mairie pendant toute la durée du
confinement
il s'adaptera en fonction des annonces
gouvernementales à venir